e passato all'incirca l'ultimo quarto
d'ora venti minuti a tentare di
sistemarmi capelli per apparire del 100
in questo blog
il risultato è quello che state vedendo
mi sono rotto i [ __ ] e direi che lo
faccio così ed attenti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video stavano
favi j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog non metto
le cuffie per che peggiorerebbe ancora
di più la situazione già grave prima di
cominciare partire con la finale della
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da angelo che ha fatto sto disegno
strabello dato why so serious and why so
serious io metterei wise pettinato e mi
si addice molto di più se come siamo in
un blog normale ragazzi volevo dirvi
prima di tutto le news prima news in
assoluto è che la settimana prossima
domani esce happy with domenica prossima
al domenica primo maggio sarà al
centesimo episodio di happy meals e per
il centesimo episodio di happy meal
voglio fare una live su happy domenica
primo maggio dalle tre di pomeriggio in
poi poi non so quanto dura ci sarà la
live diretta quindi niente portate tutti
quanti famiglia padre madre cani la
seconda chiusa ragazzi che sta per
uscire social face che ormai l'avrete si
è capito tutti che una serie che stiamo
facendo tutti noi youtubers spero vi
piaccia so che il primo episodio uscirà
anche per chi non ha sky perché è una
roba che andrà in onda su sky però
uscirà per tutti il primo episodio ci
hanno concesso sta cosa grazie a dio
allora ragazzoni me è successa una roba
utilizziamo un aggettivo non ancora
utilizzato nei miei video epica
ricordate la casa mia a milano dove
stavo prima di questa quella lì che
c'era chan tpe ragni ovunque è successo
ieri è successo mi ami fare [ __ ]
ve lo faccio vedere allora ragazzi è
successo che ieri mi ha mandato questo
uomo bello ma mandato stare questo
messaggio qui domani ore 19 a casa tua
vecchia non fare domani sto andando
adesso vediamo che cazzo mi porta anche
la videocamera non si sa mai perché mi
preoccupa sta cosa soltanto ai ragazzi
sono così è arrivato
il nostro sì state sentendo questo che
cazzo succede al santo dio che combinate
in casa milan a casa un giorno ne mela
registi che lorenzo non è stata grazie
come cazzone che casa mia non è mai
stata così popolata di gente ma che
cazzo è successo
[Musica]
poi mi ricordavo che non dovevo mettere
a posto io perché non era più casa mia
quella e allora va a fan culo lanciato
pizze in aria comunque ragazzi avete
presente marracash il rapper sono andato
un suo concerto questo tipo due mesi fa
tra mi son dimenticato di mettere questa
cosa ho fatto anche lui il classico
troll quello dove faccio finta di farmi
un selvi però in realtà è un video e la
presa così ci sono una serie a sel fi
oppure ancora questa la porta pure jesi
st grava un applauso a marra che un
fenomeno cento un altro poi volevo farla
anche a valentino sta cosa ventino rossi
solo che non riuscivo manga di e di ciao
quindi col cazzo che aveva tutta fa cosa
del celtic dopo ragazzi altre cose
strane non credo siano successe a parte
fare face suap con una ragazza
giapponese
ciao
lei è una bellissima di qualcosa
no io sono bella ciao ragazzi siccome
siamo in un blog normale ci dovrebbero
essere i fari risponde e lo scarta joe
dei pacchi solo chiede il fa vi risponde
se n'è appropriato matteo renzi e non lo
posso più fare io lo fa lui pensate che
io stia scherzando non sto scherzando
giuro allora buongiorno a tutti ragazzi
e ben ritrovati abbiamo fatto anche un
matteo rispondere un e vabbè che vedevo
di fare uno scarto dei pacchi lo faccio
io l'ho scartato mattei dobbiamo
distinguerci i ruoli va cosa non andiamo
da nessuna parte come avevo detto
l'ultima volta che i pacchi che hanno
scaldato erano gli ultimi in assoluto
gli ho mentito perché in realtà ne ho
trovati altri in gara mi avete inviato
una maglia non è importante quanti amici
si anno ma quanto valgono quelli che hai
e bellissima michele renzo e figlia e io
che ciò due milioni e mezzo di amici e
tutti quanti sono fantastici che cazzo
volete non vi è un mio figlio ma siamo
al prossimo ragazzuoli da valentina
credo che non sia questa cosa cioè mi
hai regalato un modem però non sa che
cazzo me ne faccio oppure hai preso la
scatola di un modem e ci hai messo delle
robe dentro presumibilmente sarà così
valentina stella nera valentina ciao
valentina la ragazza che mi aveva
inviato quella lettera
travolta 20 con altri ragazzi che ho
aperto un pacco di questa ragazza qui in
c'erano cose stupende qui ho paura
un'altra maglietta questa estero
addio le calze le calze di tetris per
quale motivo oddio no ma la catenina di
death note ma ce l'avevo già cazzo che
si guarda che sfiga questa è quella che
mi hai regalato tu e questa è quella che
ciò io ce l'ho uguale vabbè 2 death note
meglio che one for the next ma o
bellissimo un portachiavi di geometri
dash quanto e film quanto ti sei fare
bene i fascisti non spendo non pensare
mattina ho visto che di cimenti ai
fornelli questo ricettario a grazie mai
regalato la ricetta di un ricettario di
gusto grazie mille oddio cos'è questo
sposiamoci ho mio addio di 20 ragazzi
questo si chiama copri tatuaggio lo
metti le prendi tatuaggio metti sopra
questo è il tatuaggio si copre figo
figurale a parte gli scherzi porta a
chiave di death note number one come
farsi capire in giapponese
ma perché per fare un paio di frasi sono
i ma sempre come la sai o nei gay simas
omega cimes one greci ma come si dice
bonsai in giapponese bonsai si dice
bonsai stu cazzo non avrei mai detto
grazie mille vale anche per questo
perché quando vado in giappone a me non
so cosa sto facendo
ti ringrazio carabi regalato anche
questa foto miliardo e mezzo di cose
strafighe oh che bello un pacco dove ci
hanno scritto sopra il nome fa vj
scritto col moccolo allora ragazzi sono
io cos'è cos'è questa roba
oddio favi gemma con montegrosso alla pa
vj questo bello premino la mia vita è
cambiata in meglio
poi abbiamo la scritta 21 grazie che mi
ricordi che sono vecchio loro grazie di
ricordarmelo con dei numeri per bambini
fa meno brutto il mio amore ti amo
tantissimo infinitamente tu mi appari
sempre nella mente
sei tu il mio preferito che prima o poi
ti farò diventare mio marito abbiamo
otto anni di differenza ma la mia vita è
con te e non senza giada grazie giada
però potrei sembrare un pedofilo ma
buona ragazzi miei direi che possono
includere qui il video
vi ringrazio sempre per le cose che mi
mandate sono sempre stupende non lo so
mi diverto spacchettare le cose io anche
se non sono tipo mie io a spaccate se
avete bisogno di qualcuno che a natale
vi apre i regali faccio io cioè mi
diverte st non so perché quello non me
lo porti via matteo il fa vi risponde sì
ma lo spacchettamento non me lo porti
via lo difenderò con la forza ragazzi io
vi ringrazio sempre per le cose stupende
che mi inviate e e niente spero che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa se vi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento
è un mi piace la prossima volta che
faccio una festa in casa comunque vi
invito cioè facciamo una roba un po più
bella noi non so se ci siamo in due
milioni e mezzo in un appartamento è
però a massimo affitto anche quello del
vicino però capito mi sei piaciuto
ragazzi cosa egp è piaciuta un momento è
un mi piace anche la pagina di facebook
e come i video trascrizione ricordatevi
della live che farò su è più visto la
settimana prossima e niente domani esce
l'episodio normale 99 quindi don't
perdetevelo e noi ci rivediamo un
prossimo video belle ragazze